This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to share the teachings of a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics, Dr. Dr. Joel Wallik,
Bachelor of Science in Plant and Soil
Sciences, Doctor of Veterary Medicine,
Ford Post-Do and Pathology, Naturopathic
Doctor
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to share the teachings of a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics, Dr. Dr. Joel Wallik,
Bachelor of Science in Plant and Soil
Sciences, Doctor of Veterary Medicine,
four post-doates in pathology,
naturopathic doctor.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to share the teachings of a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics, Dr. Joel Wallik, Bachelor
of Science in Plant and Soil Sciences,
Doctor of Veterary Medicine, four
post-docctorates in pathology,
naturopathic doctor.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure.
>> Hello and welcome everyone. My name is
Ruth Ellen Sanchez. I want to welcome
you to Daily with Doc and Becca. Today
we have Dr. Lisa Singleary as our guest
and she's going to talk about some
interesting things about fat sabotage.
Also, this program is sponsored by
dailywithdocbecca.com.
No, dailywithdoc.com, sorry. And if
somebody referred you to this program,
please make sure to get back with them
as they will be your primary source for
information and contact. Also, this
program is for educational purposes only
and not meant to treat, diagnose, or
cure any diseases, nor is it meant to
take the place of your primary care
physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA
and um results may vary and any
testimonials given are experiences of
the individual giving the testimonial
and
um so
and let me see is there I'm forgetting
the okay so I'm really excited today to
have Dr. Lisa, come and join us. She's
going to open up our eyes about some
hidden fats and some different ways our
body
hide things from us and do weird things.
So, I'm going to bring her on
and um welcome Dr. Lisa.
Oh, I
welcome. I'm so glad to be here. Um, I
have to find my Zoom. There we go. Oh,
okay. Hi. See you now.
>> Okay.
>> Oh, it's so great to be here, Real. You
are amazing. I love being on the show,
but I love having this special time with
you today. So,
>> Oh, thank you.
>> Thank you for having me. I uh loved
preparing for the show with you, and you
look fabulous today. You're wearing my
colors.
>> Yes,
>> girl. Come on.
>> So, we're gonna have some fun today.
>> Yes, we are. And we are I I I feel the
same way about you. You're just amazing.
Just amazing.
>> So, tell us a little bit about yourself
and then we'll let you begin your your
talk. I can't wait to hear about it.
>> I am. And I I I will introduce myself a
little bit during the
>> uh in the presentation. I stuck a little
slide in there to talk about myself, but
>> I uh am a retired board certified family
physician
turned
certified holistic health coach. So I um
and I wasn't going to talk about this,
but I will say I stopped my medical
practice to go home and take care of my
parents. I took care of them for eight
years. I was the primary caretaker.
Let me tell you that I don't have to
tell you that is a job, but it was the
honor of my life. And uh when they
transitioned,
I mean, I found myself taking care of
them that I had to actually fight the
medical system to take care of them. And
I was out of the system. So, it didn't
matter that I had an MD and an M PH and
was a board-certified family physician
and, you know, I wasn't in the system
anymore. And I had to fight and I had to
rely on alternative methods to take care
of them. And
to my surprise, the alternative methods
were helping even better than I
expected. I didn't have, you know, I
didn't have a lot of faith in the
natural things cuz we, it was trained
out of me. I mean, I grew up with it. My
My grandparents were the neighborhood
healers. My grandfather would go into
the woods and get the barks and the
leaves, and my grandmother would make
the puses, and people would come and,
you know, trade chickens for their their
things. But we didn't get the recipes.
We didn't It wasn't passed down to us.
We just observed it. But um medical
school just completely educated it out
of me.
But there was still something there, you
know, and and this was the
70s
and uh there were some rumblings about
holistic health and alternative
medicine, but again that was the you
know pariah that was you know oh you're
just having expensive urine and you know
it I saw this this transition
through time and when I alone with my
parents with no backup, no prescription
pad, no sample closet. You know, I had
to figure out other ways to take care of
my parents. And I'm sure
that my being there with them prolonged
their lives. I'm I know it increased
their dignity. That was the main reason
I went home, for their dignity.
But um
after they after they transitioned
uh I could not go back to the system.
Also I was in a position where I was
completely broken down physically. I
needed my father's wheelchair just to
get around the house.
>> And I knew there was no prescription I
could write for myself. there was no
that that wouldn't have either kidney
issues or liver issues or get me
addicted and I would still be in the
same deteriorating body.
And so I needed the natural uh
thinking. I needed these alternative
methods not only not just for my
parents, I needed for myself.
And I was introduced to
cellular nutrition. I was introduced to
the 90 essential nutrients. I was
introduced to
the concept of being overfed
but undernourished.
And
that one phrase
um just changed my whole trajectory as
far as thinking of what could happen in
my body.
So, I'm still on the journey. I'm still
on the health journey. I'm still
learning.
But I was able to um just buy one
product. This was this is the crazy
thing. One
product
and I lost 85 lbs in 8 months. And I got
out of the wheelchair.
I got the whole 90. and you know th this
journey through the years and I'm I'm
just amazed at what has happened in me.
So I'm I'm still I'm on a and it's
different for everyone. You know,
everyone's body is different, but
everyone needs the 90 essential
nutrients and I'll talk about them a
little later.
>> Okay.
>> But that's my
>> Thank you. Thank you so much. That's a
powerful story and that is a very
powerful phrase. overfed and
undernourished.
It really makes you stop and think.
>> So, I'm gonna go ahead and Thank you so
much. Thank you. Just
I'm going to let you go ahead and do
your presentation and then we'll have
questions and um I'll I'm looking
forward to it. So, let me change a
couple things on my end and
go.
>> All righty. And I'm going to share. So,
we've tal I've been on the show before,
but I also have a weekly webinar
on um and I I have it on my YouTube the
replays on my YouTube channel, Dr. Lisa
Singleary.
And I've been talking about sabotage
and we talked about mental sabotage, the
sabotur within. Who's who's the hidden
inner sabotur on your health journey?
And we talked about the sabotage of
sugar, the sabotage of um Oh, I see
this. I I I have to fix that website.
The images are not good. But um
thank you for sharing that. Uh for
today, Dr. Lisa singlearian.com might be
better. So uh things change, you know,
the one day I woke up, all my image was
images were gone for my website. So,
uh, working on that. But anyway,
sabotage, digital sabotage, right? So,
we talked about, uh, sugar sabotage. We
talked about sizzle sabotage. When you
fry things, when you fry foods or these
high heat methods and they cause AES,
the advanced glycation end products,
heteroscyclic amines, um, acryumides, so
sabotage everywhere, right? Today we're
talking about
Oh, I got the wrong I I'm not ready to
share, but I'm going to share anyway.
We're going to talk about
fat sabotage.
So,
uh I and I I this has many different
meanings to me because
uh and I'm I I wonder how many of you
remember
some of these uh diets or
strategies that we've gone through in
the past. But what I want to do is
really focus on the fact that
not all fat makes you fat, but there are
good fats and there are bad fats. And in
our society, there's something called in
our diet, there's something called
omega6
or linoleic
acid.
And linoleic acid
back in the day was 2%
of our um body tissue and now it's over
20%. So there's something happening in
our diet in our food supply and it is
sabotage.
All right. So, you've cut the sugar,
you've cut the carbs, and you're you're
doing you're doing everything right.
You've avoiding the bad foods. You're
still stuck. What is going on? So, the
missing piece might be that there's some
fat sabotage going on.
And uh
so not all fats are the same, right? And
I want to say this too cuz I have this
on another slide, but I don't think it's
it's on this slide deck
that
when you have let's just talk about a
cheat meal. Okay, so you're on a diet
or a healthy lifestyle. You're you're
doing the healthy lifestyle. You're
committed. You're dedicated. But you've
you're going to have a cheat meal.
What happens to the different components
of that cheat meal? Well, part of the
cheat meal will be carbs probably,
right?
And
yeah, carbs can metabolically get you
off, but you can burn off the carbs in a
couple hours like with exercise even
less time. But you can, that's something
that doesn't necessarily have a
long-term impact just from one cheat
meal.
But there's probably some gluten in that
cheat meal. What do you think?
Yeah, I can think of a lot of cheat
meals that have gluten involved. Well,
gluten,
it takes about two weeks for you for
your gut to get over the damage from
that gluten cheat meal.
Linoleic acid.
Well, this is a whole different
substance because linoleic acid or omega
this particular omega6 fatty acid
gets into your cells and it has a
halflife of 2 years.
So that cheat meal, the ghost of that
cheat meal is hanging around in your
cells and damaging your mitochondria
and affecting your energy, affecting
your gut microbiome, affecting your
whole uh metabolism for years.
So not all cheat meals are all the same.
So yeah, not all fats are the same, not
all cheat meals are the same. stay on
track because these lenolleic acids are
they do they are saboturs they are
master saboturs
so um
oh I see a hand raised
uh AJ you have a question
>> are you are you talking about rancid
linoleic acid or linoleic acid in
general
>> I'm talking about Okay good question.
So, what does rancid mean? Rancid means
that the fat has started to oxidize.
And as soon as the fat is exposed to
oxygen, it starts to oxidize. So, if you
So, is here's a question. Is olive oil
good for you or bad for you? Is it a
super super nutrient for you or is it
going to work against you?
Here's the answer. It depends.
If you have an olive tree in your
backyard and you're getting fresh olives
off the tree and you're crushing them
and you're having that fresh, fresh,
fresh fresh oil, they're amazing for
you. But as soon as you crush the olive
and expose that oil to air to oxygen
then the that the clock starts ticking
on the rancid
rancidity
I think that's a word of the oil of the
breakdown of the oil and when the oil
breaks down it makes these terrible
compounds so you have to be careful you
have The shelf life is
very small
and before it starts to turn to work
against you.
>> Yes, agent.
>> And is it only linoleic that you think
is bad for us or all omega6?
>> All okay. I can't say all because some
of them are natural. some of them. In
fact, omega6 is one of the essential
nutrients actually.
But the problem is the ratio.
So like I said, we only had a small
amount of omega sixes in our diets
naturally,
but once we started processing,
then it's the amount of omega sixes in
our diets skyrocket. And that is the
problem. the ratio that it's artificial
that um it's processed.
So,
uh
all omega, no, not all omega sixes, but
the preponderance of omega sixes that
are in our processed foods and in our
food supply and that are in
uh what? So it said you are what you
eat. No, that's not true. You are what
what you eat eats. So
if you are eating processed meats
that are grain and soyfed,
then you're going to have a problem.
Even if you all you're eating is meat,
like if you have a high protein
uh diet and you know, but you have to
know the source. Where are you getting
these the meat from?
So, uh you could I get asked the
question is all
um chicken is chicken good or bad?
Right? But it depends on how it is
raised. So, you have to know your
sources.
Okay. So,
and I I I'm getting I I did get ahead of
myself a little bit here, but this is
we're still uh
um gonna have some fun. So, there was an
article doc and what inspired this was
an article by Dr. Mcola
where he talked about the overload
of linoleic acid in our modern food
supply.
And I'll show you I'll uh show you a
picture of the art or I'll give you the
link to the article in a bit. I don't
have it right in front of me right now.
Ah, I have the link. Okay, so I forgot I
put this in here. So this is the
article. This is a PDF of the article.
And if you scan that QR code, you can
get the download to this article. But
like you can see right at the top,
linoleic acid was rare
in our diets like 2% or less. Now it's
up to 25%
of our cal calories and it accumulates
in our fat tissues.
Okay. So I'm Dr. Lisa Singleary and I
told you my story a little bit but um I
will just share my framework for how I
started the road to optimal health which
is the five M of total transformation
mindset macronutrients
micronutrients motion and measurement.
And I use these five M and I share
information about these five M and
hopefully make the science simple for
your empowerment and for your
transformation journey. And we've had a
wonderful disclaimer. I also just want
to say this is not a second opinion and
your insurance is not going to pay for
me. Hopefully this is entertainment but
also educational.
So, I've got three secrets for you.
Secret number one. Where is this fat
sabotur hiding? It's hiding in your seed
oils. It's hiding in packaged foods,
restaurant meals. Just assume, right,
that the restaurant is using seed oils.
you now there are restaurants that are
more enlightened and they will might be
using ghee which is wonderful or butter
which is wonderful. I I did go into a
bakery
oh how many years ago was it? It was
over 10 years ago. But I went to this
bakery and when I walked in,
it had the bakery smell kind of, but
it just didn't have the
just the depth of, you know, just
wonderfulness that bakeries have. And so
I asked this question
um do you use I mean and it seemed like
a strange question for a bakery but I
just asked them what is made with butter
out and out of the whole display case
they showed me one little
um section of rolls or something that
actually had butter. Everything else was
made with some kind of oil or shortening
or you know something that was not I
mean who it actually I don't think I've
been at a bakery since because of that.
I was actually kind of traumatized
because I mean if you're going to cheat
you want to make it worth it, right? But
a bakery without butter but that's what
happens in our modern food supply.
People don't even know what food tastes
like anymore. I I think you know because
of everything that's packaged and
processed.
But
you even have to watch what you know
when you're cooking your own
meats because you have to know where
they're coming from. So, conventionally
raised chicken and pork can be loaded
with um omega sixes. Now, nuts and
seeds, nuts and seeds are great, but
what happens to us?
We just don't know when to stop. So, the
the nuts and seeds problem because as
long as
the nuts are intact, they're fine.
It's when you grind them and try to get
the oil. So, let's say
walnut oil, right? That's a really
sounds like a really healthy oil.
Forget about it. Walnuts,
beautiful,
but once you crush them, once you press
the oil out of them, then you're
starting that rancid clock. AJ, so um
you know, you And I don't want you to
feel like I don't want to put a whole
uh damper on your journey like oh I'm
trying everything. I I want you to I
want this to work for you. And so I just
want you to be aware of this sabotur. So
where are the seed oils? They're
everywhere.
But there are things that you can do. So
and thanks for thanks to the internet
you can do the research. If you can find
uh local farms and you can find out or
sustainable
um that you you can find uh farmers that
use sustainable practices
and um
I might have it a little later in the
slide, but I do want to emphasize
there's a difference
between or there's a Yeah, I I have a
slide coming. I'll I'll hold on on that
discussion.
Okay. Secret number two. I talked about
this a little bit. So
unlike
the gluc unlike the glucose, the sugars,
they are water soluble. Your body
processes them. You can your fat tissues
burn them off. You get energy out of
them and then your kidneys can eliminate
them. Right? or eliminate the
byproducts.
But
linoleic acid
gets incorporated into your cell
membranes. It gets incorporated into the
membranes of your mitochondria
and
over time
it oxidizes right there in place and
causes inflammation and oxidative
stress. That affects your energy, that
affects your metabolism, that affects
your weight, that gets your body like
looking for gets your microbiome looking
for a solution. And that puts you right
in front of the refrigerator at
midnight, right? Looking what can I get?
What can I get? as opposed to
if your body is not inflamed and your
rest and rest your rest and digest
system is um
functioning properly then you're not
looking for you know you're not having
these cravings and your energy is
sustained.
Okay, this is what the health halo. Here
we go.
So, this is where the olive oil
discussion, the the avocado oil sounds
great, right? Eat the avocado.
But once you once that oil is released,
then it is it starts to get rancid. So
even on the shelf and this also applies
to your essential fatty acid
supplements. Now we're very fortunate
that we have a company that we know that
our essential fatty acids are processed
in an oxygenfree environment.
And
um I actually had a a couple of
discussions with Dr. Wallik about this
about what conditions would have to
happen to have oil be healthy and it's
you know like I said having the tree in
your backyard or having it processed in
tiny batches under
oxygen-free environment and you know
packaged in small aloquats
then fine. So, it's the it's the game of
oxidation and time that makes these oils
bad, even though the source of the oil,
the olive or the avocado or the walnut
um is a healthy source.
So, eat the walnuts,
forget about the oil, the walnut oil.
Okay.
And yeah, we so we want to have we want
to balance out the omega sixs
with the omega-3s. We want the ratio to
be more
on the omega 6 side. I mean, sorry, on
the omega-3 side than the omega 6 side.
So,
um, we've heard about fatty fish, and we
love the fatty fish, of course.
What do we have to be careful about
there? Are they farmraised
or are they wild caught? So, we want our
fatty fish to be caught in the wild and
we want them small. So, the sardines are
really and um I think it was Brenda
Teresa that uh shared that on an earlier
talk that I did that the sardines are
further down in the food chain and so
they're not eating all the fatty fish or
they're not getting the byproducts of um
the omega sixes from other fish. So, the
smaller the fish and the fattier the
fish, the better. And we want to balance
those fats.
So, check your labels.
Um, swap your cooking fats. What can
What can you use? Well, butter.
Fabulous. Ghee. G h e
also fabulous. That's that's really
butter that has been has been slowcooked
until the milk solids
from the the milk or the cream are um
they'll fall out, right? And so, um I
used to love making ghee. I don't make
it so much anymore, but I did used to
love ghee. Um ask restaurants what oil
to use. add omega-3s
and yeah, add them as a meal or as add
them as a supplement as part of your 90
essential nutrients
and just small winds. Um, and we're
going to accumulate the small winds.
Okay, I see a hand. Marilyn,
you have a question.
>> Yes. Um, can you tell us a little bit
much more about ghee because so it's not
pasteurized. So can you because um a lot
of people have asked me that question is
ghee good is it filtered is it good for
us so
>> okay so what I what I do when I want
ghee and you can buy it now I don't know
the uh all the brands but what you want
to do is have ghee that is
from butter which means from cows that
are grass-fed and grass finished.
So grass-fed is not good enough because
there's a loophole
between the grass-fed that means the cow
can be was in a pasture
almost all of its life but then the last
30 days they can stuff it with um grains
and soy and you know I don't know what
they do but it They the last 30.
>> How will you know by the label? I mean,
you're just gonna have a jar that says
ghee. How do you know?
>> Well, I'm getting to that. I'm getting
to that.
>> Okay.
>> So, you will have and part of it is
trust, right? So, even if the label
says,
but you'll find you will find um more
and more that labels will say grass-fed,
grassfinished.
So the grass finished means even the
last 30 days before they go to the
market um they're fed sustainably.
They're fed they're not fed grain whole
gra you know grains and soy and stuff
like that. Um but of course that means
you're going to have a leaner product,
right? You're going to have a better
balance of omega 3s and omega sixes. And
you've got to know you you've you've got
to have a little inside scoop unless
they're actually advertising. So
to make the ghee, I used to love doing
this. You get the grass-fed
grass-finished butter
and you put it on the stove at a low
heat. And you know, I found the recipes
online. This is how this is how I did
it. but on low heat until
you'll see the milk solids
um
actually drop out of the butter. And so
instead of having the uh suspension
of milk solids suspended in the butter,
you're just going to have butter oil,
which is ghee is basically
the fat part of butter without the milk
solids, without the lac the lactose.
And that is a very stable
uh
a very stable fat for cooking.
But it comes from grass-fed grass or you
want it to come from grass-fed
grassfinished
butter.
Did that
answer?
So it's the source. We're always going
back to the source.
All right. Um
>> I was just wondering is the grass finish
is that a new thing that they just
recently started putting on the labels?
>> Yes.
>> Yeah. because we used to think that
grass-fed was the whole picture, but
then I don't know if they were insiders
or whistleblowers or what, but we found
that
um that's like a loophole
>> because the last 30 days they can real
quick fatten up the cattle and get more
um you know, more poundage out of them
so they get more money.
>> Well, thank God for them. God bless
them. Thank you.
>> Yeah. So, look for grass-fed,
grass-finish,
and that label is coming up more and
more.
>> Thank you.
>> You're welcome.
So, fat is not the enemy. Confusion is.
So, we can choose better fats. We can
cook with better fats.
um and still have I mean really what
beats butter when it comes to flavor. So
uh but I do encourage you to dig into
the ghee story because it really is a
um a convenient, it's effective, it's
healthy, it cooks well
and
it's delicious. So, what's one fat
you're going to try this week? And uh
just want to say we're just adding on
the small wins and we're on our on the
road to optimal health without the
sabotage.
All righty. Oh, there are more. Sorry, I
forgot
this was a slide. I thought I was going
to have this earlier. Okay, so I took a
fad diet trip down memory lane
and a hundred Can you believe that? 100
years of diet trends. How many of these
diets
have you try been exposed to or tried or
heard of? So the 20s was just counting
calories. the 30s, the grapefruit diet,
the cleanse, master cleanse, the cabbage
soup diet, wine and eggs.
I I was a kid during that time, so I
missed that one. But um the Atkins diet,
I met Dr. Atkins and uh he was he was
his research was very impressive.
The reduced fat diet. Oh, what was the
name of that diet? It was T something T.
Anyway, there was a there, you know,
that was it. Cut out the fat. Well,
this whole time. Okay. The zone diet. I
met Dr. Barry Sears and the zone diet. I
love the zone diet. The South Beach
diet.
Any hand raises? Right. Paleo, keto,
whole 30, plant-based, glutenfree,
which is not a fat, right? We want to be
gluten-free.
And now we're focused primarily on high
protein, not necessarily full keto, but
high protein with healthy carbs uh
balanced in.
So I one of my frameworks is also the
five steps to nutritional completeness.
Step number one, we have to get the diet
right. Everything is built on the
foundation of the diet. And you know,
people are like um
when people try to say that
uh I don't know
that we're spending so much money on
supplements and uh strategies and I'm
like look just cut out the bad foods.
Don't even ask me about anything else.
Cut out the bad foods. Eat the good
foods. See what your body does. body
will thank you, right? But if you want
to get to optimal health, we need to go
up the ladder. So, step number two, the
90 essential nutrients. Step number
three, antioxidants, adaptogens,
anti-inflammatories.
Step number four, you are not what you
eat,
you are what you absorb.
And you are what what you eat eats. And
then absorb. And then step five, you can
target your I mean there's a whole I
can't even name all of the strategies
that are in step five. I call it
wellness wonderland.
And um yeah, your infrared light
therapy, your cryotherapy,
your brain support, your targeted joint
support, your you know, any
uh energy healing, any uh strategies,
they're all in step five for me, and
they're great, but they have to be built
on the first four steps. I see your
hand, AJ.
you have a question
>> uh after you're done.
>> Okay.
So,
what are the 90 essential nutrients?
They are 60 essential minerals, 16
essential vitamins, 12 essential amino
acids, and two to three, and that's a
whole another story why it's two to
three essential fatty acids.
But here's what we need to know.
The word essential, what does it mean?
What do you when you think of the word
essential? What does it mean to you? It
means you need it, right? Well,
medically, and that's true, but
medically,
biochemically, the word essential means
your body can't make it. So you have to
get these things
onboarded somehow whether it's through
your mouth or through your skin um via
your food or via supplementation.
So it's really important to to find the
essential
nutrients from a great source that is
trusted and stick with the basics. And
then you can add on, you know, your
trips to Wellness Wonderland. But we got
to we got to have the the first two
steps in place
primarily.
So I have a gift for you. I call this
the um the lipid lexicon, I think. So
we've got so many words that we talk
about uh lipids, fatty acids,
saturated polyunsaturated triglyceride,
omegas, phosph cholesterol. So they I
asked for all of these
uh what is it?
Um where is it found and why it matters.
So for each of these terms, so here's a
quick little guide. You can uh
scan the code if you're on your phone.
Just take a screenshot and then, you
know, email it to yourself, scan it
later. And um hopefully you've gotten
some
information
and without being too overwhelmed with
all of this because you know it can be
overwhelming. But we also want to be
able to have the information that we
need to help ourselves on this wellness
journey.
AJ
feel free to unmute.
>> Dr. Lisa, I think that that was
profound. And you know, I always ask Ben
uh when our shows are going on, I say,
"Ben, what's the source of the obesity?
What What is it? What's going on? How
come uh we're obese?" And he's a
metabolic syndrome.
And when you kind of just talk right now
about the omega sixes uh damaging the
mitochondria causing metabolic syndrome.
So that is profound.
I when I see the guy delivering Lays
potato chips going forward, I will slice
the tires.
And this is the interesting thing that
because all of those diets through the
years come from, you know, some of it is
fads, but some of it comes from
research, right? So research has changed
or we we've gotten more knowledge
through the years. We do better studies
and there's more investment
in healthy
uh eating and uh now more than ever. But
if you look at
the graph for the rates of obesity
through the years, it's relentless that
it's up up. It doesn't matter what diet
we've tried or you know what is in the
feds, it's gone up. And I think a major
reason of that is because of people
missing the 90 essential nutrients. So,
and yes, the diet, you know, the
insidious fats in our diets, but
um when we don't have the essentials,
then our bodies start to crave. And when
we crave,
all bets are off, right? I I call it um
Niserati syndrome. like when you are
planning to eat something healthy and
actually the day I named it, I was on I
was on keto for the time and I was my
big plan was to go to Wendy's because
they had a grilled chicken Caesar salad
and instead of bread croutons, they had
uh crispy cheese
like cheese crisps
and I just thought that was the best
thing, right? So I was I get the grilled
chicken Caesar salad and the unsweetened
iced tea and I got up to the window to
pay and she says, "Oh, you got the
number one with a Coke." I'm like,
"What?"
I mean, I literally my brain blanked
out.
I with every intention of ordering
healthy, but at the moment that the
words came out of my mouth,
I don't even remember saying the words.
>> And then I got up to the window
>> ready to pay for my salad and unsweet
tea. And she's like, "Oh, you ordered."
I'm like, "What?"
>> And I looked back and I'm like, "Wait a
minute. I was I was right there."
>> That's horrible. I call it Nisradi
syndrome which is not so random acts of
temporary insanity.
>> NR a ti.
>> Well, I I I I very much appreciate the
fact that your journey is helping so
many of us. You know, Paul Croto uh
always talks about uh we get too many
omega sixes in our diet and but you've
really enumerated it well and I
appreciate you.
>> Thank you,
Key B.
>> Thank you for unmuting me, Ruth Ellen.
Um you mentioned a couple things. Um,
first I want to tell you I appreciate
you being here. Um, what you've had to
say, it makes a big point. Um, and I'm
going to come around to that in a
minute. You said that when you started,
you started on one product. I was
curious as to what that product was.
>> BTT, baby.
>> Okay.
>> 8. So that's 87 out of the 90, right? In
one scoop, one
>> out of the 90. That is absolutely
fabulous given the fact that you gave a
list of all those diets. You sort of
when you went on the down that runway
and mapped time, you know, you have
those diets of like South Beach and I
remember the Scarsdale diet and the
diet, all of those other ones.
>> Yeah.
>> Um given the fact that everybody's
biochemistry is different,
>> um and they're making lifestyle
preferences,
>> do you see something working better for
men than women? And if so, what would
you say that differential might be?
>> Everything works better for men than
women when it comes to diets. And I
think it's because of hormones. Um
because we our bodies are designed to
produce, you know, to to duplicate
humanity and to nurture. And the baby's
going to win, right? the I can't tell I
can't tell you I can't tell you from
personal experience but I have cared for
a lot of expectant mothers. I've
delivered a lot of babies and those
mothers man the babies just go through
the the babies are relentless in getting
their nutrition from their mothers and
that's their only source right but the
mother's mother mother's body will
sacrifice for the baby and that is um I
believe a biological imperative that uh
for the
for the furtherance of the species
that women should carry more weight in
in different ways than men do. So,
>> so is there a particular, you know,
given all the women that you've worked
with or individuals that you've worked
with, if you were going to make a
recommendation for, I hate to use the
word diet because, you know, the first
three letters are die.
>> Um, but if they're going to make a
lifestyle preference choice, is there,
you know, do you, you know, recommend
like Mediterraneanish? Do you recommend
a carnivore-ish, a ketoish? Um, and I
say ish because, you know, we're all
going to fall off the wagon at some
point in time.
>> Or do you just say that it's up to your
biochemistry and you're just going to
have to work it out over time?
>> First,
uh, get the 90 essential nutrients.
Without getting the 90 central
nutrients, your body is you you are at
the
behest of your microbiome, you know, of
your um body symptom systems
looking for what they need.
Uh
as far as
uh naming a diet, so this is when I met
Dr. I actually met Dr. Atkins and Dr.
Sears on the same day.
I was I was on a search for
I I
red clover started this search. So
someone came to my church and said they
were selling nutrients and they were
saying red clover cleanses the blood.
And I'm like how can you say that? You
know what does that even mean? Like I
can understand a redux reaction. I can
understand you know pH and alkal
alkalinization and you know I can
understand those things because they
were starting to be in the news too. But
when you say red clover cleanses the
blood how I I like it just blew my
alopathic brain. I was like
but
I wanted to know like can anybody
explain this to me? So I started me on a
little search and I found a group called
AAM, the American
College for the Advancement of Medicine.
And I don't even know how I found them,
but I saw their letterhead and on their
letterhead there were MDs, DOS,
ND like but mostly MDs and DOS were were
on their board of you know scientific
adviserss on their head. I was like,
"Okay, I can learn from these people."
So, I went to the conference
and one day they had they called it a
food fight and
um the they had six presenters
and including Dr. Atkins, Dr. Sears,
there was a Mediterranean diet
representative, there was a vegetarian
I I it might have been Dr. and Andrew
what's his name? Uh
I didn't I wasn't I didn't catch I
didn't remember the name of the other I
just was starruck I guess by Dr. Atkins
and Dr. Sears.
But there had been multiple
scientific papers presented during the
day. And
every single paper, whether it was on
rats or mice or humans, every study
showed that carbs,
excess carbs, right, caused issues. And
every single study tried decreasing the
carbs a cert to a certain percentage.
And so and Dr. Atkins was the last
person on the panel to speak.
And he said, "You've all been proving
what I've been saying all along, that
you have to cut the carbs. I just cut
them to a
a more of an extreme than you do." But
that's because I work with people that
have extreme issues.
So,
um I think it's a matter of
somewhat a matter of personal
preference, but and a matter of
physiology, but I also think part of it
is uh a matter of where you are on the
planet.
So in the Mediterranean,
the Mediterranean diet, you're using
local fresh ingredients, etc., as well
as the Mediterranean
way of cooking. So I think the
Mediterranean diet is fabulous.
Um,
but and I mean I
there are many approaches, right? And
so I would say and and this is really
what Dr. Atkins did. He didn't he didn't
um
you had to read his books to really get
that what he was doing, but he had you
uh find out your own level of carb
tolerance,
right? So yes, there's a certain amount
of it that's physiological I would say.
But the the main thing is get the get
the essentials
and get a good food bad food
uh regimen that you will follow
because yes AJ human nature we will
cheat.
>> Um yeah I I love Dr. Atkins and I always
did a South Beach sort of like modified,
you know, keto. Um, that's where I've
always had my best success. Um, but now
I've gotten to the point where I can't
stand protein.
>> Ah,
>> I hate meat. I hate meat. It's I have
the gag reflex, but that's a totally
different issue. Uh, thank you for that
answer. And then the last one comment or
I'd like you to address just sort of
generally given the fact you talked
about the omegas recognizing that we
offer them as part of the protocol. Can
you sort of differentiate for people
that are looking at these protocols and
they may be saying, "Well, do I take
these omegas? Do I not take these
omegas? Are they just related to the
extra junk stuff of the omegas in the
junk food?" If you can make that
differentiation. And the last one is, if
we're getting too many omegas, how does
that affect us women with hormones and
our lymph as we are dieting?
So, let's just say for the the the fact
that we are in America with the food
supply that we have, let's just say
omega sixes are on the bad side and
omega-3s are on the good side. So, we
want to focus on increasing the balance
or the ratio of omega-3s and decreasing
the omega sixes. So, some of some of our
supplements have
uh a good ratio of omega-3s and omega
sixs. Some of them are just omega-3s.
Neither one is wrong, right? Because we
want a good balance. But
for me, I um I do double and triple up
on the omega-3s
and
just I I also when it comes to what are
the extra compounds that are in like
people will say that this essential
fatty acid is good for the brain. This
essential fatty acid is good for the
heart. this essential fatty acids is
good for you know what the liver
whatever
part of that is and this is part of of
looking at the research and I know you
know how to read studies doc
um but the research that we have
available is based upon
who has paid
to have the research done right somebody
has to have an idea oh I I think DEA's
might or DHA might help help um the
brain. I want and they get someone to
pay for a study that proves or that you
know shows that thing. Does that mean
another type of omega-3 won't help the
brain? No. It's just that that was the
one thing that was studied and got
published.
So, when you get your omegas from a
natural source,
then you're getting multiples,
right? Or if you get omegas or if you're
focusing on the omega-3,
then you're going to help that ratio.
So, I I don't really
um
get too into and I I did I I dug into
every single type of fatty acid and then
I realized, well, this one, you know,
they just they did they're not saying
this one doesn't help the brain. It's
just it wasn't studied and documented.
Gotcha. And that last piece about if the
is the assumption I guess I'll ask this
question. Is the assumption
can somebody make a hypothesis andor an
assumption that if you have extra omega
sixes and you're attempting to lose
weight, you're trying to, you know, eat
clean, whatever clean is these days, but
not the 12 bad foods. um is the
assumption that there is a correlation
of that into lymph for women as they go
to reduce their cortisol and their
weight.
Do you think there's any connection
there or correlation?
>> I don't have the research on that. But
if you say connection and correlation,
absolutely.
>> Okay.
So we just have
>> connect because well every single cell
in our bodies is a lipid billayer.
And what does that mean? It means uh the
backbone of a glycerol with two fatty
acids. That's the lipid.
And they're just
millions of them, billions of them,
trillions of them, right in our in our
cell membranes. And so when these things
are incorporated into the cell
membranes, it affects the cell function.
>> So therefore I I would say that that is
one way to focus or one way to turn
the metabolic picture in your favor is
to really ramp up the omega-3s.
>> I think I'm going to take a deep dive
with you.
Y
>> quality time with Keely. I love it.
>> Okay. Thank you so much, dear. I really
appreciate your um your brain and your
knowledge.
>> Thank you. And if you look I don't know
if you look on my um YouTube channel, I
did a
uh webinar called
uh
what fat makes you fat. And it was it
was really my first webinar on the
omega-3s. And so I did have an extra
article that I dug into in that uh
webinar as well.
>> Okay, great. Thank you. Look forward to
talking to you.
>> Awesome.
>> Thank you, Key. You bet.
>> And that was amazing and good questions.
Um
>> it's what fat makes you fat.
>> Yeah. What fat makes you fat? Yes. I was
going to say something about something,
but I got um I forget now. Um
I know that a lot of these diets I've
tried most of them over the course of my
life that you had mentioned
and um I know that when I'm like I'm in
the journey of losing a little weight
right now and releasing it I should say
releasing weight and uh sometimes I get
to a point where
I'm not hungry but I want something and
I want something and then I realized
that uh oh I didn't take my tangy today
or I didn't take um something else that
I should have taken today and uh so then
I take it and 20 minutes later I have no
more cravings and I'm good
and I I just um really appreciate you um
bringing the different topics that you
bring and you do a really good deep dive
and explanation on all of them.
I just appreciate you so much.
>> Yes, thank you. So that word diet and
>> yeah the first three letters are die key
>> but
that statement of being overfed and
undernourished that
that made my
approach not one of deprivation
but one of abundance.
And so when I stepped into the abundance
of the 90 essential nutrients,
my body was like, "Okay, I can I can let
this go now."
>> And um you know, it made all the
difference for me. And it was, yes, you
still have to do all five, the motion,
you know, you the macros, the micros,
you need everything. You need it. But
yeah,
>> to break the cycle
>> and to to give me the breathing room
mentally to make good decisions,
I found the difference was having the 90
essential nutrients
in my system.
>> Yes, it it makes a huge difference.
I mean, when I first started um taking
longevity supplements, I was over 220
pounds
and I just started to lose weight, you
know, and it gradually came off and I
lost a lot of weight, but I went through
a journey in the last few years and I
gained a little bit of that weight back.
So, it's back to it. And yes, men, you
have it so easy sometimes. My husband
lost 50 pounds off the bat. and crusty
200 again.
>> Okay, let me say something about the new
GH the GHL,
>> right?
>> Taking them at night, taking them at
bedtime doesn't help you. So, I did that
because I just was in, you know, with
the more the rise, the restore, I had my
my rhythm of my supplements. But the
whole purpose of the GHL is to make you
feel full so you don't eat as much.
So when you take it at night, that's not
helping. You got to take it before you
eat. So take it during the day.
>> What is the GHL? Is that the essential
fatty acid?
>> I'm sorry. G L P1. That's it.
>> Oh yes, in the morning.
>> Okay. Okay. Good morning.
>> My other passion is internet marketing
and I've been looking at go high level
and someone introduce go high level to
me. So that's what GHL is. So
>> Oh,
>> GLP1.
>> Yes. Yeah. I take that in the morning.
Um, and
and that I like the fiber that comes
with it because it has all the stuff in
it that is in the and you can buy that
separately that's in the um sweeties.
So, it helps with the sugar cravings and
the different things and
>> and yeah, I went to a wedding a couple
weekends ago and I had um
I cheated. I've been strictly carnivore,
watching where the meat came from and
the dairy came from and everything, but
strictly carnivore. And then I went off
for this wedding
and I had a piece of gluten-free cake,
which oh my god, Rosie, that was the
bomb.
Um, and then ever since then, even
though that was like two weekends ago, I
keep like wanting like that I have that
little itch and I'm just not going to
eat sugar. That's it. No more sugar. And
so, thank you so much. It looks like Key
has another question or something. Do
you still have time to take another one?
>> Sure. It' be my honor.
>> Okay.
Haley,
>> given the fact that you just brought up
the GHLGPT1
system, you lost your 85 pounds on one
product and you know doc teaches that
you bring that body back into balance on
the essential nutrients and then your
body basically does the rest. That sort
of begs the question, so why do we need
the GLP1?
>> What would be the Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So
um
if you are taking again the 90 essential
nutrients are the foundation they are
essential. Um, I think a lot of it is
because of human nature,
right? We just need a boost. We just
need a some oomph, some uh motivation.
We want to see some results. And when
you do see changes quickly, then you're
more likely to stay on program. So um
you know I if you're and this is the
thing when we take the 90
I'm talking now up to
the 2.5
right so the original the 2.0 the 2.5
we took that per 100 pounds of body
weight
um I altered it a little bit with the
3.0 No, because
the the rise
is mostly a brain
um support or has a lot of brain support
in it. And all of our brains are the
same size. You know, they're about is
three lbs.
So,
we don't need it per body weight. We
need it per brain weight. So, I don't
recommend doubling up on the rise. I
can't wait till the restore comes out
separately because I will be buying
restore like two to one to the rise
probably something like that. That's my
personal preference. But um but what I
do per body weight now is the minerals.
So if someone is on any really of our
healthy body start packs, I also add
the planteride minerals
um
one, two, three extra doses uh per day
and that is the per body weight
um that's the way I prescribe
the per body weight idea.
Yeah, that's good. And I didn't even
think about the rise. It is mainly for
the brain.
So, yeah, that definitely should be by
your brain weight.
You just need one. But I I I also add
the um plant derived minerals. And
that's one thing I've kind of slacked
off on. And I put the the mineral sticks
in with different things and um
to kind of help with getting more
minerals in and to flavor like the Greek
yogurt that I eat and you know different
things.
>> Well, the rise and restore together
has so much in it.
>> It's so good.
>> So good. It's so good. But it only has
150 um milligrams of minerals.
>> Yes, you need extra minerals with that
for sure. Definitely plant derived
minerals. Yeah.
>> Mhm.
>> Right.
>> Yes.
>> So the it's the extra minerals are
non-negotiable
with the rise and restore.
Key, you made my day. You can buy
restore separately. Now
>> you you have to call it in
>> and ask for it.
>> I didn't know.
>> Yes. I'm sorry. I should have told you
that. I forgot.
>> I didn't know. Key D for the win.
>> Yes.
>> Zack GZ.
>> All right. Go ahead. Let me help ask you
to unmute.
>> Hi Dr. Lisa Singleary. Hi everybody. I'm
just so excited. um on the GLP1
and man it's working really good.
>> We don't want to hear from any men.
>> No,
>> I know. But Zach, I I celebrate your
journey. I've watched your journey and
yes, you are doing amazing.
>> Well, and I'll tell you, I got three
ladies on the program and trust me,
their self-esteem has gone up. I' I've
heard everything from 12 lbs in one
month to um just their abdomen just it's
it's it's life-changing.
Um all I want to say is why do I take
the rising restore and I want your
input. Dr. Wallock on his book Health's
Kitchen mentions that when you burn fat
there's a lot of byproducts and you need
a lot of antioxidants.
That thing has 300,000. That's the
reason I take it. I don't want all that
burn fat to stay in my system. Just
what's your take on that?
That's the reason I take the rise and
restore. I don't want no none of those
byproducts cuz I'm burning fat really
fast. I can see it. My pants, you know,
I might have to get some new pants and
some new belts here. I'm excited. This
works. Thank you, Dr. Lisa. Thank you
for all the good info today. I
>> That's wonderful, Zach. Thank you. And
yeah, the
an ORX score of 300,000. I thought it
was okay. When the when the BTT tablets
came out, so the original BTT
the Orax score was listed as like 5,000
and the BTT 2.0 O was like 8,500
and um you need I mean a plate of
broccoli was like 50 to 500. So that's a
lot of ORAC in uh in the 5,000 to 8,000
range.
So when the BTT tablets came out and it
said
140 nound
uh 46
I think it was 160,000
170,000 something like that. I was like,
"Oh no, the company's got a they're got
they got a typo in their labels. They're
gonna Thank you. 160,000." Yeah, they
got a typo in their labels. They're
going to have But that's okay, you know.
And then I've heard Steve Wallik it.
That was really the number 160,000
and that's for four capsules.
Well, on a normal day, a person needs
about 50,000.
Mhm.
>> And a person that's challenged needs
maybe a 100,000
200,000. This is this is I have increase
this from back in the day. And if a
person has a big health challenge
that might start with C,
um then you're talking 300,000,
you know, in that area that you're going
to have that much oxidative stress in
your body that you need to have um a way
to neutralize.
So
those ORAX scores, oh my goodness. And
you know, science the the research is
not kind for orac scores,
but um that's part of the equation and I
think that's a huge value that we have.
So
>> yeah, it's
>> that got me excited talking about score.
>> I know I've never ever in my life of
being involved with different
nutritional companies had anything with
the ORX score like that ever. And you
can feel the difference. I mean, I
remember when I first started, I tried
to drink my full dose of body weight
because I was over 220 pounds
>> and I tried to drink it. Uh, and uh I I
I got I don't know like five minutes in
and I wasn't guzzling it, okay? I kept
taking sips and it was like, "Oh my god,
I need to stop." because my body was
just buzzing with the B vitamins and the
nutrients and I could feel it and I
called um the person that I signed up
with and and said um should I be doing
this? What's happening? And they're
like, "No, no, no. Just do half and then
half divided because all at once is too
much and sip it through the day, you
know." Um, it it's an amazing product
line and and also I want to, you know,
clarify for everybody who's watching the
replay and everything, Youngevity has
its own GLP1 nutritional supplement
formula that stimulates your body's own
GLP1 and activates it naturally without
any other kind of antagonist
or venoms or any of the crazy stuff
that's in the other ones. And I can't
say that. So I, you know, just it's
natural. We'll just say that.
AJ's giving me the hands.
>> Okay. So I did
>> I see the message about my links. So on
some of the site you will see if there's
a link that the domain is Dr. Lisa
singleary.online
online
slash whatever, Google has has gone on a
rampage
and is making it difficult for any of
those links. And so this red page might
come up or what, but if you click
through and just go, you know, keep
going, it's fine. It's, you know,
they're all secured. They're all good,
good links. But I'm in a fight with
Google now, right? I mean, they're even
going into my drive and saying this
document, you know, we don't like this
document. And it's a even if it's a a
document that I don't share,
>> so
>> they shouldn't be allowed to go into
your drive. Period. It's private
>> and I've none of their dog on business.
>> Yeah. Well, they don't like it. Any any
document that I have that has that
domain and so
>> Oh, the domain. Okay.
>> I have a link I have a list I have a
spreadsheet with my uh websites and with
my freebies that had that domain and
it's like
>> I'm not even sharing it but so I'm
working on it but all of the links are
good.
>> So if they just go to drl lisa
singleary.com
then without the forward slash and
whatever it is they should be okay.
>> Dr. ly singleary.com is good, but I have
I I have to check. I may have put some
links on that site that are
drilling.online.
>> Okay. Okay.
So, but you know, trying to brand my
domain, trying to keep the brand, and
then, you know,
>> so I'm I'm I'm uh hanging on the
coattails of people like AJ just trying
to figure out this internet thing.
>> Yes, me too.
>> Me, too. And um Marilyn, you have your
hand up. Just a quick question.
You have to unmute.
Marilyn, you have to unmute. There you
go.
>> I'm sorry. It was just about her links.
I just want to make sure.
>> Okay.
>> Thank you so much. I had a feeling
that's what it was. Okay. Thank you so
much, Marilyn.
All right. Um, if we can, um, it's Thank
you so much, Dr. Lisa. We always get a
lot out of what you teach. And, you
know, I consider you a mentor.
I like to look at your stuff and and
learn from you. And um
I can't wait to have you on again. So
after I'll call you in a couple days and
we'll figure out your next time to come
on because we love having you on. And if
I can get my co-host to come up on the
screen, we'll start wrapping it up. And
while that happens,
everybody need to spotlight yourselves.
Pretty please.
Thank you. Um,
I just want to say again that this
program is sponsored by dailywithdoc.com
and we do have a phone team with a uh
that is available 247.
Um, it is 8559493377.
You can call that and speak with a
certified holistic health coach. And if
somebody doesn't answer, you can either
call back or leave a message, but
usually someone will pick up.
And then we also would like you to uh if
you have any questions, go to questions
at dailywithdoc.com
and um
and you can ask questions there. But I
need you to please, please, please. I
can't say enough pleases here. Leave
your phone number.
Leave your phone number because every
once in a while the emails don't work.
When we try to email back, it doesn't go
through. People say they don't get them.
And I don't know what's happening. If
it's a Google thing, if it's a whatever
website you have, browser,
whatever. But if you leave your phone
number, it's easier for us to call you
back and then we can just, you know, go
over some things with you. And if you
prefer email, say, "Here's my number."
Just in case you don't hear back from
me, or whatever you want to say. But if
you could do that, that would be very
helpful. Um, also,
tomorrow's show, now this is very
important, it is going to start an hour
late. that we will start at 400 pm
Eastern time, 1:00 Pacific time, because
we have a very special guest tomorrow.
Are we announcing the name of our
special guest for tomorrow, AJ?
I don't think he's listening to me.
Okay. Um,
>> I'm supposed to give the name.
>> No, I just asked if we're announcing.
I'm going to announce.
>> Please do. Oh, we should announce.
>> So, tomorrow we are going to have one of
the best
constitutional attorneys
anywhere on. He is the man who helped
Dr. Wallik sue the FDA and win. He also
made it so that we can talk about
essential fatty acids and actually say
that they're good for your heart and
that selenium is good and so many other
things that we probably don't even know.
So, Jonathan Eort
is going to be on with us tomorrow. So,
we're starting at 400 p.m. Eastern time
on the 8th of May. So, tomorrow,
come later, I'll post it where I
normally post everything and the email
will reflect that. But I'm really
excited. Um, get your questions, raise
your hand early, post them in the chats
early on the different platforms if you
have questions for Jonathan.
And, um, a shout out to Becca Dukes. We
miss you. And um
okay, so I'm going to go through the
co-hosts now. So we have Sherry,
post them in the chats early on the
different platforms if you have
>> Thank you AJ for that.
Um
I'm sorry I'm just teasing you. So, we
have Sherry who is part of our tech crew
and she helps set up the different
platforms, Facebook and Rumble and um a
bunch of them that go out on a different
platform that we use. And she is also
a fantastic
fermenttor and herbalist and we love
her.
And then we have we have Albert who is
our gatekeeper and he is in South Africa
and he lets people in and monitors and
make sure everything is okay and if
you're bad you get kicked out but we
haven't really had that problem for a
little while so that's good. Um, and
then also he is the person that you will
get in the middle of the night if you're
calling the phone team phone number of
8559493377.
He's the one that will answer because
he's awake while we're sleeping.
And then we have AJ who is our digital
marketing director who is making an
interesting face right now. Smile AJ.
um and he helps us get out on a lot of
different platforms and we're grateful
for that. And then we have Marilyn who
is Miss Speedy Fingers and she is typing
away in the chat and she even looks
things up and then uh posts them. I just
am amazed at the ability that you have
to type that fast because I definitely
can't. And my name is Ruth Ellen
Sanchez. I'm the executive production
manager for Daily with Doc and Becca and
I'm just grateful to be able to be here
and help you um bring out Doc's message
and keep it going fresh into the world.
And um Dr. Lisa and our different
guests,
we're just grateful for all of you and
thank you so much for what you shared
with us today, Dr. Lisa, because it was
very informative. Thank you everybody
and we hope to see you tomorrow at 400
p.m. Eastern Standard Time. Thank you.
Thank you. Bye for now.
This program is for educ. educational
purposes only. The content is not
intended to diagnose, treat, cure, or
prevent any diseases, nor is it intended
to take the place of your primary care
physician. The statements in this
program have not been evaluated by the
FDA. Testimonials are shared as
individual experiences of the
individual. Results vary and may not be
typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to share the teachings of a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics, Dr. Joel Wallik, Bachelor
of Science and Plant and soil sciences,
doctor of veterary medicine for
post-doates and pathology, naturopathic
doctor.
This program is for education. ational
purposes only. The content is not
intended to diagnose, treat, cure, or
prevent any diseases, nor is it intended
to take the place of your primary care
physician. The statements in this
program have not been evaluated by the
FDA. Testimonials are shared as
individual experiences of the
individual. Results vary and may not be
typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to share the teachings of a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics, Dr. Joel Wallik, Bachelor
of Science in Plant and Soil Sciences,
Doctor of Veterary Medicine, Ford
Post-Does and Pathology, Naturopathic
Doctor.